no one is no one is born with
self-confidence zero right every single
one of us our self-confidence was
determined by how we were raised the
parents we had the teachers we had the
bosses we've had the jobs we've had my
sister worked for a company for 17 years
and her boss destroyed her
self-confidence she came out of that job
and she didn't realize until she got
into her new job how afraid she was to
make decisions because of her boss and
it took it took a while for her to get
her confidence back and so if somebody's
insecure we have to over and over and
over again prove to them because we
don't know where they came from we don't
know what kind of trouble they got in
before for being honest right or what
how they were raised we don't know and
so we have to total empathy and just
prove to them that that if they make a
mistake they're gonna get helped not
hurt they're gonna get supported not
yelled at and it the first time they
won't believe you they think it's a game
they think it's a con it's a trick the
second time maybe and we just have to
keep at it that every time I used to
have I used to have somebody on my team
who would regularly lie to me right
because she would rather lie to me then
tell me that she made a mistake it was
in and I could and if I saw the lie I
would ask so many questions to get her
to say to me I screwed up I'd be like
well this doesn't make sense because I
can't say you're lying to me right I
just say this doesn't make sense this
doesn't make sense if this adds up to
this then why is it that and she would
scheudle I would get bigger and then she
would yell at me about how I don't trust
her and then at the end after be like
listen it clearly doesn't add up I am
okay if it doesn't add up if you made a
mistake just tell me I'm good and we'll
move on but when you deceive me I'm
gonna ask you so many questions to get
to the truth that it's gonna get worse
and worse and worse I had to have that
conversation with her probably 50 times
before little cracks started to show
where she showed up to me once where one
number wasn't there and she looked at me
and said I made a mistake and I went
cool Thanks
Alan Mulally puts it brilliantly he says
you you have a problem you are not the
problem
right so something goes wrong we have a
problem but you are not the problem and
that's the point is we've too many times
told people that they're the problem so
I think it's just gonna take time and
patience and you have to do the hard
work of helping that person build up
their confidence again
[Music]
[Music]